[Music]
excuse me I'd like to open up an account
well great what type of account do you
have in mind this kind this kind
[Music]
they excuse me need some help good let
me take a look you know anything about
cars no not really
[Applause]
it's a lot about you what did you say
you well that's the secret
every [ __ ] is that
spent his whole life locked up so for
the times that he broke out he broke out
of San Quentin and eight vote sixteen
successful escapes there somebody
shoulda told me quit lines in well you
find something you love
[Music]
it's big real big knows how I got that
truck
you think we can pull it off yeah I
think we can probably do it properly
we're gonna be 67 years old I'm gonna
start to get about my future so how did
the same three guys get away with all
that well haven't gotten away with that
things haven't been caught yet step on
it
just one way stretch out my arms and
cried
just one day guy with a gun it just kind
of a funny story
you can catch him myself so if I get the
chance
ever wonder what I'm doing or where I'm
going I just think of myself as that
little kid I was now what he'd been
proud of me
what was he proud of you Bubble Boy
oh he's getting closer every day
[Music]
you